three two one
it's a boy and he's here
[Music]
nikki bella and professional dancer
artem chavinsev have welcomed their
first child together
the 36 year old professional wrestler
announced she was pregnant in january
saying i can't even begin to describe to
all of you
how happy i am i'm going to be a mom
it's something i've wanted to be my
whole life i thank god every day and
night for bringing this amazing blessing
and miracle into my life i am already so
in love and get this nikki's twin sister
brie
also announced her second pregnancy at
the same time
to be a week and a half apart it's crazy
to me it's mind-blowing but i have to
say
i actually like it yeah because bree's
my encyclopedia i go to her
on the daily every day about everything
because i look at birdie and i'm like
she turned out great so i'm gonna follow
you and it's kind of been like really
fun i just don't feel alone in this
process
and we have the same cravings the same
symptoms like same everything
in june nikki opened up to eti about
those cravings and shared how she and
her sister are treating themselves
during their pregnancies
i love protein shakes bree and i both it
is so weird
and artem's like that out of anywhere i
could drive you through
cinnamon's down the street you want a
protein shake i'm like yeah it smells so
yummy throughout her pregnancy the pro
wrestler has documented her growing baby
bump on social media
he's been very very active especially at
night but
um just so much throughout the day i
love it
he's sleeping right now though and
shared her beauty tips to prevent
pregnancy stretch marks
i do this routine every morning and
night
and then sometimes during the day
cameras were also there for the couple's
gender reveal party which aired during
the season finale of total bellas in
june
that same month nikki told it whether
she wanted cameras in the delivery room
while giving birth
i am totally still want to film the
experience
um as of now only artem can be in there
so artem would have to film
um but we're praying that by the time i
deliver that great because i really want
green there with me
and i'm hoping that we could bring a
total bellas producer so brie and artem
can just be in the moment with me and
not worry about
filming as for being pregnant during a
pandemic
nikki said she was happy to have artem
by her side
we're lucky because so artem's here with
us too and he's been cooking a lot of
our meals
we have increased our meditation so much
because
you try not to panic being pregnant
because this is not how i imagine my
first pregnancy to be
i imagine my first pregnancy could be a
lot different so i'm trying to embrace
it
nikki and artem first met in 2017 when
they were partnered on dancing with the
stars
the two later reconnected and went
public with their relationship in march
of 2019
and got engaged in france in november
[Music]
oh my gosh yes
oh my goodness and now
it's a party of three having a baby it's
crazy all the love
oh my goodness
that is so cute the baby will for sure
represent
you